joining me now with reaction is Dan
bungee no fox news contributor and
author of the book exonerated along with
chris on former aide to Senator Chuck
Schumer and host of the aggressive
progressive podcast now guys the crew is
gonna tell me in the back when they have
those sots ready because I really want
to share those with you and the audience
it's amazing what Americans are saying
but Dan your reaction first to this
notion that whatever Nadler and the Dems
are planning all of this impeachment
drama will it get lost in the holiday
hubbub in the holiday above raven it's
already lost listen the news cycle now
is not even 24 hours it's about 24
seconds the attention span of most
people is their twitter feed on one
scroll this was a nothing burger from
the start there was nothing there I mean
with Clinton we had actual perjury
involved whether impeaching him was a
good political idea I think history is
told a different story with Nixon there
was an actual burglary that happened
right with this there's a alleged quid
pro quo which nobody can tell you they
heard it directly from the president and
the quid pro quo keeps changing it was
supposedly about military aid then a
White House meeting then a public
statement America's get this thing off a
week ago it's a political disaster for
the Democrats Chris your reaction to
this I mean obviously there are people
who are going to debate whether there
are grounds for impeachment here doesn't
seem there is or it would be much more
of a slam dunk and the polls wouldn't be
moving in the direction they are which
is away from impeachment but will the
holiday season play a role in this
trying to pitch this impeachment in the
midst of the holidays well everything
gets lost in the holidays Raymond I mean
here we are the night before
Thanksgiving and Happy Thanksgiving to
both of you on one of the biggest
liberals in America and Thanksgiving is
still a thing we all celebrate okay but
yes it will get lost somewhat in the
holidays but then the new year will roll
around and there'll be a trial in the
Senate and everybody will read the
bottom of page three and the top of page
four of the transcript that the
President himself released and it will
show where the president held up the
Ukrainian president
for dirt on his political opponent and I
think that's a slam dunk as you need to
get everything else collaborates what
the President himself said on that phone
call okay guys I want to show you before
I go to my next question I have to share
with you the shots we got on in New York
City on the streets well let's go to
this first the media is salivating over
this New York Times report today that
Trump was briefed on the whistleblower
complaint before releasing aid to
Ukraine listen to this reportage to that
the only reason he released the aid is
he got caught in this whole scheme the
president decided to release the aid
when he knew his cover was blown
once they knew that the gig was up and
they were about to be discovered they
took steps to try to have this final
defense of well we gave up the aid so no
harm no foul
in fact gentlemen there may be another
explanation for why Trump released the
aid it has to do with a conversation he
had with Senator Rob Portman a member of
the Ukrainian caucus on September 11th
here's how the president explained it
back in October and I want your
reactions because he called up please
let the money go I said Rob I hate being
the country that's always giving money
when Ukraine helps Europe and the
European countries far more than they
help us this was my only reason because
I don't like being the sucker country we
were the sucker country for years and
years dan is the idea that the president
was briefed before he released this aid
that he was told about the whistleblower
complaint is that the Silver Bullet to
take him up you know listen I love you
rabbeted that silver book this case is a
joke I mean Chris isn't your like you
guys are humiliating yourselves on the
Left running with this I don't
understand how you didn't learn from the
Clinton impeachment what did the buckle
this is going to be whew you are
literally gonna get Trump reelected this
silver bullet to have a case of bribery
or whatever extortion or whatever buzzy
words they use quid pro quo you actually
have to have someone on the other end of
it who actually is aware of the bribery
or the quid pro quo and
Oh Ukrainian official has backed up this
story yet this is total nonsense
it's a fabricated scandal it's a myth
Chris your reaction so dan dan so so the
Congress appropriated this money the
President signed the bill there's a
thing called the impoundment Control Act
which the president violated by not
informing Congress that he was holding
this money up
senator Portman informed the president
of this on September 11 he was also
informed about the whistleblower and
that's why this aid was released not
necessarily Chris don't already know
what they're gonna learn it this is
number 30 the truth he's violated the
impoundment you stroke on when he held
it up without nobody can hear you when
you're talking over each other President
had any courage at all if the President
had any courage at all he would let his
aide speak to Congress and get it out
there if he really thinks he's okay
Chris and the president should be doing
Jason your reaction the talk go ahead
Dan okay quick chris is just making that
up again I you know liberals are good at
that everything's in reverse improper
control that guy ya know it exists Chris
but of course you're making it up he had
until September 30 to pay the money out
the president actually dictates way far
and no he's gonna go yes Dan the
president sighs obligated to spend them
so you're just making that up and no
this isn't an open-and-shut case it's
not even a case at all well you've got
it again to prove the case and even to
make this new bombshell stick you'd
really have to get into trumps mind to
know exactly where he was in that moment
that's a hard thing to prove even in a
hearing now I want gentlemen I want to
share with you how people are reacting
real Americans on the street to this
impeachment drama when I asked them are
you going to be focused on the holidays
or on Nadler and the impeachment march
watch this Christmas season will you be
focused on impeachment or Santa Claus in
the holidays Santa Claus in the holidays
absolutely Sanok
sanim I'm gonna say Santa don't judge me
Santa Claus and getting rid of the
Democrats impeachment absolutely
impeachment why because it's important
you won't be focused on impeachment will
not and patron is a waste of time it's a
waste of time yeah so you're gonna be
jingle Belling all the way I think I'll
go to 34th Street see if there's a
miracle there that's what I was
referring to earlier when I said the
Democrats may want to get in the line
but one of those miracles Chris isn't it
a hard case to make and why do you think
the American people are walking away
from this well a 2% movement in the
polls is not walking away 3% of gold
just now statistically insignificant
Raymond but it is the holidays and after
this hit tonight I'm not talking about
politics until Monday and I encourage
every American to do the same exact
thing leave it alone for a couple days
it'll be waiting for you on Monday we
could all relax and have a nice holiday
well everybody has a nice Christmas
season as well and doesn't get too
bogged down in this I want to go back to
a time where we didn't think about the
President of the United States every
minute of every day well you know wasn't
chance of it Chris Chris Dan and I would
support that okay in the spirit of
Thanksgiving I have to share something
with you a left-wing group and and dan
I'm gonna let you react moveon.org it's
urging followers to talk to your family
about impeachment this Thanksgiving is
this a good idea damn that seems
undercut old grits please I'm begging
you in the Fox audience do not take move
on don't listen listen I rarely agree on
anything on this network that's why
people like the wait like these segments
when Chris and I both and the host
Raymond are both agrees is a miraculous
moment do not do this
yeah this is a moment of jerky gentlemen
do not yell at each other get on Monday
okay we're gonna have a ceasefire for a
couple of days we're having a spoiler
for a couple of Thanksgiving ceasefire
and we're just gonna watch football and
Turkey and love our families no
political fighting gentlemen thank you
both for being here
go play Monopoly Thanksgiving happy
Thanksgiving to you